we've seen plenty of recreations inside
the forge but Xbox Live user turb tastic
has taken the map editor to a whole new
level he's remade rocket League inside
of halo 5 and it plays pretty close to
the real thing instead of driving an RC
car you'll pilot a ghost as you try to
hit a green soccer ball into your
opponent's goal thanks to a capture the
flag modifier the map will even keep
track of those goals and you can get out
of your vehicle if you want but don't be
surprised if you get immediately
splattered you can play the map just
like rocket League with two to six
players but it does have one advantage
over its counterpart crank it up to 16
players and you'll have to juggle three
soccer balls at once I think that
qualifies as a hat-trick rocket league
is coming to xbox one on februari 17th
but turb tastic SMAP is a fine
substitute for now ever since the forge
tools released back in december we've
seen some amazing maps keep your sights
on gamespot because the more you guys
build the more we'll have to share